who gets caught more men or women oh men
for sure oh yeah we're good at lying who
gets away with cheating more men or
women but women don't get caught we're
smarter about it have any of you been
cheated on no no no no oh wow never no
you have to [__] have like so how did
you find out he cheated having another
girlfriend and then I found out you had
enough girlfriend did you leave when you
found out no how how long did you stay
after you found out six months maybe six
months then I realized on Valentine's
Day when he's spending half the day with
me and the half day with her it's not
really good is it but I was young I was
17. you're a seven so that is very young
right now never but back then I was
stupid